le ministre de l'Agriculture regrette
que le gouvernement en 2016 est interdit
tous les néonicotinoïdes il demande un
débat européen ça ne sert à rien de
produire des interdictions qui affaisse
des pas entiers de notre souveraineté
agricole et agroalimentaire quand de
toute façon les autres peuvent le faire
parce que à la fin ça veut dire que nous
pourvoirons à nos besoins par des pays
tiers d'abord européens mais parfois à
l'extérieur de nos frontières dans cette
interdiction complète des
néonicotinoïdes à partir de 2023 ce
n'était pas la volonté du gouvernement
français c'est une décision de la Cour
de justice européenne qui s'impose à la
France la France avait d'ailleurs fait
voter une loi dérogatoire pour prolonger
leur utilisation c'était en 2020 en 2020
où vous étiez député déjà à l'époque
Fidji et vous vous avez voté en faveur
de cette prolongation de l'usage des
néonicotinoïdes pourquoi cette position
alors que ça fait quand même un moment
qu'on connaît les dangers de cette
substance pour les abeilles mais aussi
pour certains mammifères et même pour
les êtres humains mais pour une raison
simple et ça a été très bien dit dans le
reportage il faut des produits de
substitution et ces produits
substitutions on les a pas alors de
revenir à l'histoire et date de 2016
c'était Ségolène Royal qui était
ministre de l'écologie il y avait
d'ailleurs une barbara Pompili qui était
secrétaire d'État et j'étais à l'époque
député qui était intervenu pour faire en
sorte que l'on trouve une solution
transitoire donc qui a été rappelé
jusqu'en 2022 et là la décision de la
Cour européenne de justice est tombé le
19 janvier la veille d'ailleurs du la
date du 20 qui est la fameuse date à
laquelle il va y avoir le fameux conseil
qui expliquait si ou non on allait
trouver des solutions et si oui ou non
on a les prolonger ou pas encore pour
une année les néonicotinoïdes ce qui
n'est pas acceptable je vous le dis très
clairement c'est que en Allemagne on
continue d'utiliser des produits ce qui
n'est pas acceptable c'est qu'on puisse
importer des betteraves du sucre ou des
produits dérivés d'autres pays du monde
et donc sa raison pour laquelle le
ministre Marc féno a activé le 30
janvier le 30 janvier dernier au Conseil
des ministres à Bruxelles de la culture
la clause de sauvegarde pour protéger
nos agriculteur mais entre temps il faut
trouver des solutions pour nos
betteraviers parce que sinon il y aura
plus de betteraves
Fournier quand la gauche était au
pouvoir avec tes écologistes en 2016
que je sache il est pas de programme de
recherche les programmes de recherche
très précisément je sais parce que à la
commission je suis allé voir sur pièce
et sur place il date de 2019 c'est là
qu'on a commencé à mettre de l'argent
sur la table vraiment avec inrae avec
l'ancêtre et avec qui TB c'est-à-dire
que l'institut qui gère justement les
semences du betteraves et tout ce qui
touche autour des betteraves alors
32 essais très précisément il y a 32
essais qui ont été lancés et on n'a pas
encore la bonne solution il faut
accélérer le rupture l'assurance se
retrouve mais moi ce que je peux pas il
y a deux choses excusez-moi la bonne
solution
il y a deux choses qu'il faut dire c'est
qu'en 2020 je suis allé dans les champs
constaté qu'avec ces pucerons cette
jaunissent parce qu'il provoque cette
journée en Eure-et-Loir 65% de moins de
rendement donc on doit être en capacité
de trouver des produits de substitution
sans nocivité même si j'ai entendu le
sait très bien on n'a jamais vu des
abeilles sur les fleurs des betteraves
parce que de toute façon la première
année là-bas toutes les fleurs
que on n'a jamais vu des
la deuxième chose c'est qu'on ne peut
pas ne pas avoir une homogénéité à
l'échelle européenne ça c'est
inacceptable que l'on mette nos
agriculteurs et vous savez que la France
est allée on parle de déficit commercial
l'agriculture c'est plus 5 milliards
d'euros et moi je ne veux pas je peux
pas laisser faire que en Allemagne en
Belgique en Espagne on divise des
produits chez moi ça c'est juste pas
possible alors qu'il faille trouver les
solutions alternatif qui faille
accélérer la difficulté qu'on a alors le
ministre Marc feyde la filière a très
rapidement on aura probablement un
témoignage qui arrivera tout à l'heure
il va voir ce qu'on appelle des plans de
campagne qui permettent quelquefois de
récupérer ces fameux pucerons et
d'éviter qu'ils allaient se positionner
sur la betterave il y aura des nouveaux
parcours techniques qui vont être mis en
place il y aura une indemnisation parce
que nous avons voté l'année dernière une
assurance récolte mais j'ai envie de
dire on va essayer de colmater les vrais
faut qu'on soit en capacité de trouver
des solutions alternatives
du CNRS me donnent des publications de
Sayan sur nature qui sont des revues
absolument
incontournables dans le domaine médical
en plus biologiste
tout à l'heure il y en a quand même des
études hein tout à l'heure on a moins de
rendement c'est vrai mais est-ce que on
peut obligatoirement faire en sorte de
se mettre là encore une fois de plus en
situation de faiblesse moi je dis
simplement pour la protection des
natures je pense qu'il n'y a rien à
démontrer dans mon territoire j'y
croyais avoir été votre présent sur
notre très nombreux rendez-vous ce que
je veux dire c'est que prendre une
décision seule tant qu'on n'a pas la
substitution possible c'est compliqué
donc là on est sur une année transitoire
chacun a bien compris moi je souhaite
que il y a eu un programme national qui
a été lancé justement il y a trois ans
parce qu'entre 2016 et 2019 si je l'ai
dit tout à l'heure c'est que j'avais
insisté pour le fait que rien n'avait
été lancé en matière de programme de
recherche sur
enfin sous l'impulsion de Julien de
Normandie en 2019 il faut maintenant
accélérer pour pas laisser simplement
des betteraves rentrer du Brésil par
exemple avec du sucre dont on connaît
pas du tout la production regardez quand
vous regardez par exemple le problème du
blé avec le glyphosate qu'est-ce qui se
passe le Canadien les utilise des
glyphosate et après on introduit du blé
en Europe parce qu'il rentre par
certains ports je peux pas laisser faire
ça je ne peux pas laisser une situation
du concurrence déloyale s'organisée
sachant qu'en plus le ministère de la
culture c'est ministère de la
souveraineté alimentaire et que ça sur
Internet alimentaire c'est pas un mot
vous faites l'avocat d'une filière ça
fait vraiment l'avocat mais l'avocat non
mais l'avocat moi je dis que il faut
bien que on peut se dire terminer il y a
plus rien j'entends tous les messages ce
que je veux simplement c'est qu'on
trouve des solutions de substitution le
soutien cette filière on comprend que
vous voulez c'est votre position aussi
mais en tant que comme de médecine euh
cette production de sucre est-ce qu'il
faut continuer à la soutenir quoi qu'il
advienne est-ce que c'est important que
la France reste le premier producteur
mondial de betterave sucrière est-ce
qu'il faudrait pas tout simplement
admettre que mon produit trop de sucre
et qu'il faudra consommer moins mais
vous savez que combien on a perdu de
pourcentage de production de sucre
depuis 10 ans en France
on a perdu 30% 120 000 hectares en moins
donc on produit moins je veux bien
Charles Fournier OK et puis dessus mais
c'est quand même la vérité et la surface
cultivée au betterave a diminué de 30%.
dès le moment où on efface pas rentrer
des produits de l'extérieur parce que je
sais que la traçabilité en France elle
est bien meilleure il n'y a pas de
position sur le plan de la sécurité
sanitaire et la préservation tant de la
nature entre nous que des individus vous
pouvez pas dire le contraire vu ma
formation mon parcours mais en revanche
une fois de plus incite lors d'une année
de transition l'assurance récolte qu'on
aille lancer l'année dernière est utile
mais j'espère qu'on va déboucher en 2023
sur le fait qu'il y ait de nouveaux
produits posent pas de difficultés
particulières avérées et qui permettent
sinon de continuer à ces productions
sinon on se met en état dépendant
regardez ce qui se passe pour les
engrais avec la guerre en Ukraine vous
avez vu ce qui s'est passé l'inflation
des Anglais vous avez une traçabilité
parfaite voyez j'ai plus confiance dans
les cultures françaises que j'ai
confiance agriculteurs qui vient du
monde entier il y a 10 ans à ouvrir des
contain poivre voyez de crevettes qui
venaient du Vietnam mais sur lesquels on
les avait traités sur le foyer on peut
avoir des missions d'investigation de
l'Assemblée à 5h du matin
on s'est aperçu il était crevettes et
traiter à l'oxygénée pour les conserver
un peu plus longtemps mais moi je ne
veux pas de tout ça oui une alimentation
des qualités d'ailleurs à mon territoire
il le sait très bien on a même lancé un
programme alimentaire de territoires
pour faire des circuits plus courts pour
nos écoles donc voilà simplement je
voudrais pour les vitrailler pour
terminer sur ce sujet c'est
utopique de dire qu'on consommera pas de
sucre il en faut et il faut une très
bonne traçabilité et accompagner des
agriculture créer de nouvelles taxes
c'est quelque chose qui est envisageable
pour vous filmer parce que on sait que
vous avez aimé une position personnelle
mais au nom de votre groupe le modem
pour éventuellement trouver de nouveaux
moyens de financement pour
parler un peu du contexte du débat ou
même d'épargne cela il nous reste 4
minutes d'émission quand même quelques
instants
depuis quelques années jamais il y a eu
un texte avec autant d'amendements
et une stratégie de blocage
voulu par Monsieur Mélenchon qui a donné
l'ordre à cette troupe dans la nupède
donc les écologistes comme les autres de
dire surtout vous bloquer vous allez pas
voter l'article 7 très mauvaise image du
Parlement pour tout le monde la gauche
la droite le centre le rassemblement
national qui est resté caché dans son
coin moi j'aurais bien aimé poser la
question Madame Le Pen quand on cotise
40 ans et qu'on démarre à 24 ans et
compare à 60 avec quelle retrait-on pas
et oui il y a eu une décote importante
mais ça dépend n'a pas pu la voir donc
après on a un débat qui est structurant
Marie zolt Touraine a fait voter une loi
en 2015 que je sache qui prévoyait quoi
le quotidien depuis longtemps 43 ans
2035 donc en fait c'est la vérité
qui était ministre sous François
Hollande voté par les socialistes ça
veut dire en clair avec quoi à la clé
mais tout le monde a oublié augmentation
des cotisations des cotisations
salariales ça veut dire 0,1%
c'est-à-dire 2,3 milliards de pouvoir
d'achat qu'on est allé chercher dans les
poils des salariés nous sommes sur le
fond est-ce que vous du côté de la
majorité vous êtes prêts aller chercher
là-dessus c'est clair c'est net c'est
simplement sur le plan le Commissariat
au Plan qui définit ça ça a été contesté
par personne retrouver des sous pour
trouver des sous soit vous cotisez plus
soit vous travaillez le déficit compris
par le président français
j'ai lu les 8 versions pas du tout
relisez la page 11 du corps et vous
verrez qu'il est établi qu'il y aura 450
milliards d'euros de déficit dans 30 ans
non il y a plusieurs scénario possible
c'est 22 milliards d'impôts qui sont
versés non mais soyons très précis je
connais parfaitement de ces questions 22
milliards sont payés par l'État au type
de compensation et oui mais là pour les
régions spéciaux ça sert donc par
exemple des visites mais c'est
malheureusement ces chiffres ont été
contestés par personne mais même la
gauche monsieur gay peut-être que
Charlie peut connaître
par personne peut-être par vous quand
même personne de conteste qui aura sur
25 ans si les prévisions du corps sont
justes un déficit mais ce déficit il est
relativement maîtrisable c'est à peine
0,8 points de PIB
alors donc déjà pas 30 milliards comme
ça a été et puis on donne des chiffres
cumulés pour donner le sens
en rajoutant la contribution de l'État
qui moi me pose pas de problème qui est
une contribution de l'État pour
équilibrer les systèmes ça me paraît
tout à fait légitime c'est rien si on
remet ça par rapport à ce que peut-être
le le déficit public c'est ça va pas
mettre en danger notre pays et puis
surtout des solutions de financement il
en existe si on revenait sur des
excusez-moi on n'aura pas
mais il y a une chose le déficit est
bien de 30 milliards
va se poursuivre ces prochaines semaines
et ceux qui veulent là il est
incontestable on y reviendra on y
reviendra sur prochaine semaine on avait
pas l'intention d'épuiser le débat